what's up everyone this is Anthony popli
I know most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain simply
the best podcast in crypto let's kick
this thing off
Darius Dale is managing director and
partner at hedge I risk management in
this conversation we discussed a macro
economy monetary policy the role of the
Federal Reserve China's economic
development bitcoins future potential
and the importance of financial literacy
in today's world I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do for a
while he may be the only person I know
who I'm willing to drink with talk
macroeconomics and then go on a football
field and beat them but yeah that's a
special place in my life thanks for
coming to do this you even have the swag
on absolutely swag absolutely all right
let's go through your background first
and then we'll get into macroeconomic
stuff you grew up where Seattle yeah so
uh I was born in kind of a podunk town
called East st. Louis at the time it was
the murder capital of the United States
so kind of my fun run-in with that that
old crowd we moved my family moved to
Seattle when I was I think I was 11
years old
uh-huh it's sort of got involved in
sports and whatnot and that kind of kept
me out of that those uh you know those
those communities yeah we got to talk so
you what uh went to Seattle and played
football only mm-hmm
yeah play high school football at West
Seattle shot the clothes program shot
the clothes rope you listen man you
can't be shouting out your high school
team if they were scrub my senior year
we were the first less Seattle high
school football team since 1954 I
believe to make the the Washington state
playoffs and you want to know the last
play of the the leaked City
Championships they called on 4th and 6
on 4th and goal from the 6 yard line
they called a dive right to run right
behind me I picked my D end up drive him
in the end zone fall down pancake him in
the end zone roll over and the running
backs right next to me with the ball in
the end zone I am fair so you guys want
state championship
no no bounce to the first round we
climbed the mountain the mountain don't
matter how big the mountain is
all right so you end up gonna play
football at Yale mm-hmm
why Yale yeah I heard that school sucks
yeah it's funny God another funny story
there so I um you know my family I grew
up you know very poor you know for lack
of a better word you know we didn't even
have the Internet in high school and
this is back in the day where you just
you know you just didn't have any
exposure outs you know you don't have
the internet and certainly I don't think
a lot of people in the young and
generation you empathize that now but
information was not ubiquitous back then
I was getting recruited to play football
you know for some pac-12 schools the
biggest probably being University
Washington which is our hometown school
um so I was pretty set on going
University Washington fact it's the only
school I applied to at the time I'm
playing football there but my high
school coach knowing the student that I
was student athlete that I was sent my
VHS and this is tape for younger Jewish
it's a black rectangle that you stick
into a VCR you used to come yourself
yeah there was no website then all those
kids used to have to stick these things
in and record football games these giant
boxes anyway so he sent my tape to uh to
the coaches at Yale and they started
recruiting me you know when they first
got there when I first met coach Reno
was now the head coach at Yale he flew
to Seattle to visit me when he left my
school I I literally when my friend
asked me oh who's that from because they
were used to seeing coaches come in and
recruit me I go I don't know some small
school in India I had no idea I'd never
heard of you I had no idea what
significance of going to Yale was I
heard a Harvard and Princeton for the
movies but I had no idea yell was part
of that sort of a lead institution base
so you know fast forward fast forward
into my second semester senior I'm still
set on going u-dub I'm still getting
hounded by coaches at Yale put Craig
McGowan who's my ap marine biology
teacher at the time in high school he
was also the head of marine biology at
the University of Washington where I was
sort of dead set on going to school he
pulled me aside after after our final
heading in a second semester and goes if
you don't like I I don't know tell you
basically is what he's saying but I can
make sure you don't go to university you
should go to Yale but if you're too dumb
to figure that out I'll make sure you
don't go to university and that's when
everything clicked so that was very
first time I got on the plane so the way
the first have you ever got on a plane
yeah what's go my visit yeah really yeah
so you said AP classes you want here
great one No
when I got to college a kid was show me
a schedule no we were freshmen and I was
like hey Mei how come you ain't got a
math class and he was and I thought like
idiot you know you didn't schedule one
and he was like I don't have to take any
and I was like what'd he mean he's like
oh I took up in high school I was like
what he's like yeah AP classes and I was
like oh my high school didn't have that
and he's like now I'm sure that they did
you're just an idiot I was like no I we
didn't have that like I wouldn't know
yeah he's like well you should like
maybe ask somebody so I called the
smartest person I knew and I was like
hey do we have AP classes they're like
yeah I took all of them you were in none
of them we got a mutual friend who are
at the high schools but uh no and I
remember thinking like oh wow man Mike
you could have taken classes in high
school that count towards college like
yeah and I was busy playing sports and
also to him look at you yeah well here's
what's funny so you went to Yale I went
to buck now and we would go play I think
we'll I played at Yale one year and then
we go play Harvard or Princeton all
these places and and Yale always cracked
me up because they cared like I got
these other schools like um they would
leave what everybody yeah like the fan
scared totally man we had a good fan
base no we were pretty good when we were
there and I think that sort of fosters a
community around you and also New Haven
is a great town you know you have is not
a rich tradition around that Yale
football program yes maybe not less so
today with you know the advent of this
you know the internet and TV and all
these big TV deals for college football
but back in the day when it was just
here in hometown team yeah yeah it was a
big time you know 60 70s and into the
eighties what uh what's your biggest
takeaway from being a student at Yale oh
man my biggest takeaway from being a
studio Novas might take away it's
something I would go back and do had I
known I would I would have challenged
myself more academically I wouldn't have
been afraid to protect my GPA as much as
I was sort of I felt academically
inferior coming from a you know
inner-city public school it wasn't the
worst school you know I did get to go to
a better school than I otherwise could
have but but you know certainly wasn't
the quality of schools they're playing
the game of school I was playing the
game of you know don't look like an
idiot around all
he's really really smart people yeah
Paul Paul Graham's got a great thing he
just wrote where it's you have to learn
to unlearn and it's the whole idea that
like most kids when they go through
college or high school they're basically
they've learned how to hack the test
right it's meaning that okay so you want
me to pay attention to all this
information and at the end of the course
of the semester or whatever I'm gonna
take a test yeah and if what you know I
think the example uses like medieval
history or something right he's like if
school actually optimized for learning
which you would do is you would go read
the five best books on medieval history
right and then you would walk away back
I know the most about medieval history
that I possibly could like I should pass
his class but instead of what they do is
they have to watch for that test and
that test is based on the notes and the
lectures that that teacher gave and then
so if you want to pass the test you
shouldn't go read the five best books
and so you should read the teachers
notes guess what in college it's always
like half the books of written by the
professor that's their data and the
tests are all floating around when she
brings up right and he's like you know
the teacher who's been teaching for
fifteen years can only ask so many
questions so they end up getting
recycled by accident or on purpose
whatever and she end up optimizing for
the test yeah and his point is when you
leave college you end up optimizing for
tests and you don't even realize it so
when you're building companies right how
do i fundraise well fundraising isn't
the point of the company absolutely it's
just a test right how do I get that job
how do I you know you start to optimize
your life around the same thing school
taught you but if you can unlearn that
their shoes your bandages oh my god it's
so you hit the nail on the head whether
it comes to companies in education like
it simply on companies your business
should be principally focused on solving
a problem that your clients face they
have a customer base face that that is
that is the literal single most
important variable to determine you know
successful businesses sex enterprises
relatives on successful ventures that's
what you do when you left school oh so
I've been joined heheh so let's let's
backtrack on in terms of how this all
played out so it's you know 2008 you
know the world's in financial crisis
financial ruin a lot of my buddies
aren't getting offered at their
internships and on Wall Street you know
I only sort of late you know I'd only
become a sort of good enough student
kind of late in the game just even
consider Wall Street and I actually
started to take it seriously but I kind
of missed that whole sort of you know
goldman sachs internship Oh
those that aren't aware the wallstreet
get an internship participate in the
summer that starts heading a near junior
college at the latest go to brother
Jimmy's on the weekend bar
yeah whatever the new new hottest intern
bar is but but it's pretty competitive
it's very competitive and that starts
you know these won a lot of these kids
being groomed for life for these kind of
opportunities I wasn't even aware that
the opportunities existed yeah once I
became or being on it became very
interesting to me however I was you know
so just kind of late to the curve so
you're kind of kicking the tires trying
to look for an offbeat and path to get
into the financial services industry
I actually saw an ad in the whitey in
the Yale Daily News that says we're
hiring
it's a full-page ad I mean I've never
really seen an ad no idea I mean it was
by hedge eye CEO Keith McCullough at the
time this is back in 2008 since we're
hiring because no one else is hiring on
Wall Street and you know hedge I see he
also went the L is the Ock captain in 99
and he you know he said look I'm gonna
start a company he's I think he was 33
or 34 the time I want to start a company
I want to I have a vision for where
research is going to go independent
investment research is gonna go I have a
vision for where for the mediums in
which finance is gonna you know sort of
change and in terms of the communication
mechanisms and delivery mechanisms of
information I think that's gonna change
I mean I need a bunch of young analysts
that I really can't afford it Wall
Street breaks to come work for me and so
I was part of that first cattle class of
analysts you know um you know kind of I
guess the longest surviving one yeah
others have gone off to business school
done do some really great things around
the world but yep you know I certainly
survived what you guys do when you first
got there I was this pitch to you uh
well its pitch to us was I'm employing
you so that's the first pitch but
secondarily it was an opportunity we
work at a startup like you know it was
an opportunity I'm a partner now I'm you
know the co head of the macro team with
Keith and I you know I've been a guy for
ten and a half years now and the
opportunity to build something was the
pitch you know wasn't gonna be lavish I
mean I remember plenty of days were the
heat in our office when were working we
were right on the office campus so I
kind of lived in New Haven for seven
years I three years after college before
I moved to New York you know it was it
wasn't glamorous but it was awesome
because you could just see the wheels
starting to turn
as our collective knowledge based glue
our client base grew and our feedback
net loop all those things kind of you
know kind of grew exponentially over the
years yeah and so talk a little bit
about what you guys actually do and then
we'll get into the macroeconomics yeah
we've seen this year yeah so hedge I at
its core is a sort of distillery of
invest industrial grade investment
research you know kind of the coal
genesis behind the name hedge eye is is
sort of you know it it's it's what what
you would see if you looked into view if
you have a high-class hedge fund had
transparency around their investment
decision-making processes so Keith is
former by cider had a prolific career on
the buy side you know it's some very big
shops and some very big positions had a
really successful career really want you
know during his non-compete when Carl ah
blue waves venture blew up he basically
said I wanted to recreate my team I want
to recreate my process but blogging is
just as easy as me managing money if not
more there's no competition in the in
the in the investment research fear I
mean you talk about the people he's
competing with you know on TV and it's
not much better you know on the sell
side you know in terms of the
traditional banks and brokers is you
know if only because of their conflicts
of interest so you know what we're
trying to do is effectively show
world-class process in terms of
investment decision making and then
share that process with you know
institutional Bester's hedge funds
mutual funds pension funds and then we
touch sort of investment advisors we
touch retail investors you know there's
a there's a product set and a product
solution for each of these people even a
price for each of these people and it
and it works it's a great business and
so as you guys do that like talk to me
about what is the deliverable is it a
hey we've done work on this asset class
in this country here's how we view it
we're thinking that long over the next
six months is a good idea here's the
product to actually get that exposure
and like here's the ideas is it vehicles
that they can invest in like how do you
actually interact with the clients yeah
so it's mostly through sort of do the
various mediums I think the one of the
keys great visions and I think I'm
actually shocked that no one is try to
compete in this arena that he sort of
kind of built is that the fact that we
create you know marketable consumable
content you know traditional in no
matter how good the research is on the
cell phone on the in head
in Wall Street it's it's delivered in a
very boring very traditional sense
here's a PowerPoint presentation here's
a research note we're gonna do a
conference call we said the hell with
all that we still do all those things
because that's kind of you know the the
lowest notation yeah that's expectation
that's kind of lowest common denominator
of communicating but what's beautiful
about hedge eyes you know not only do we
have world-class analysts and
world-class research that is good if not
better than most you know and I don't
mince words about that it's the fact
that we created and presented in a you
know in a consumable format so we have a
video team we have a lot of very
expensive live full studio in our office
you know we can produce video content
you know consumable video content that's
you know on par with anything you're
gonna see on CNBC and Bloomberg and so
when you sort of canary the fact that we
have great analysts great investors you
know you know with with repeatable
transparent processes and accountability
I think that's another thing that's
unique to edge eyes the fact that we're
accountable to all of our calls you know
a lot of investors a lot of a lot of
people will kind of do what we do or at
least on the side of Finance you know
they'll pop up when something's going
well for them and they'll go away when
it's not going well for them we're on
we're in our clients inboxes every day
we're producing video content every day
I'm on Twitter every day you see you not
interact on Twitter it is it is about
you know just being there for the client
if the client may be a portfolio manager
at a trillion dollar asset manager you
know would you have couple of those if
the clients a guide managing thirty
thousand dollars in his PA
you know we've a lot of those as well
yeah let's go around the world a little
bit in terms of different asset classes
of what's going on let's start here at
home in the US what would you guys see
in 2019 come from a macro view point
yeah so I mean you know 2019 is gonna
really interesting use by those Kaos is
probably the most interesting chaotic
year of my career in terms of all of the
different sort of kind of macro things
that happened relative to sort of this
some of the expected outcomes and I uh
namely use the sort of unity returns by
in fact I'm not even sure what the year
day return is to me it didn't just to us
in general investing is not about your
date your date is a compensation scheme
that's for that's how hedge fund
investors get paid that's how you know
the people in Wall Street get paid it's
not about year-to-date it's about when
did you make this decision and how well
did the decision do in terms of you know
performance and so to me the biggest the
biggest call of 2019
was the duration duration for your
losers I don't know it's it's it's sort
of the the the insensitivity to interest
rates so we had a view that interest
rate to fall going back this is going
back heading into the q4 of 2018 if you
recall you know for those who are in
finance you couldn't have a conversation
in finance if it wasn't prefaced with
okay so rates are going to forward to 6%
on the 10-year what do you do from there
we we stop that conversation Dennis
tracks and say okay the economy is about
to inflect and ready to change terms
inflation is about to inflect the rate
of change terms and it's very likely
that bob bond yields get cut in half
from here that was a great call but all
the things associated with that making
that call were also great calls like
being long housing being long gold being
long the dollar dollar tends to go up
when financial conditions are tightening
you know things of that nature so that
was a good year for us in that regard
I wouldn't it's probably a mixed year in
terms of calling stocks because I mean I
think no we definitely got the sector in
South factor exposures right but I don't
know that we were sort of as exposed to
sort of the quote unquote year to day
return if we could have been we
certainly weren't exposed on the
downside in q4 of last year we actually
made the call that the market would
crack and be led to the downside by more
cyclical sectors and sell factors in got
it and so how do you think about let's
just call all of the Federal Reserve and
the geopolitical slash just political
stuff going on in terms of like the the
instability or the uncertainty right so
you've got a M word you've got a
president that is raging multiple trade
wars right or these threatening multiple
ones and engaging in some of them you've
got a Federal Reserve that has chosen to
cut rates right it looks like you were
forced to cut rates okay so explain more
well the force that coverage so the
Federal Reserve tends not to do what the
bond market since suggesting so you go
back into you know what kind of
catalyzed the rate cut and you know
heading into the first rate cut in July
it was a summer time soon in May was a
degradation in economic data and was a
rise and credit spreads that we saw you
know in the second quarter of this year
in the Federal Reserve you know jpowel
don't forget is a worth a hundred
million dollars you know worth DeCarlo
he's a private equity guy his singular
forced and foremost job as Federal
Reserve Chairman is to make sure the
credit cycle gets used to work and
actually think he's doing a fairly good
job of it I think he's sort of certainly
elongated the business cycle with their
actions they took this year
I'm in terms of monetary z but that
doesn't mean the business cycle goes
away so somebody once said to me people
think that the Federal Reserve job is to
manage a currency and what they forget
is their job is to manage an economy
their job is to manage the liquidity
don't I I can we can talk about this for
to a point that more absolutely the Fed
the the one I had a very very important
to say to say the least
bond investor teach me this a few years
ago this is probably sort of 2016 and he
said the the the most important driver
of economic activity of inflation of
investor expectations is liquidity
it's the supply and demand balance or
imbalance between maturing debt
obligations and the cash to invest in
new ones or so that the cash from the
maturing ones and the supply or the the
lack thereof supply of new demand for
credit and so as long as the Federal
Reserve can have a policy setting that
facilitates that in a really sort of
productive manner that's actually quite
good for the economy that's the virtuous
cycle that we tend to see you know when
the economy's doing well it stocks and
credit are doing really well when that
breaks in it's hard to it's you know
it's a lot of these these are private
debt instruments it's hard to understand
when that could potentially break and a
lot of times that breaks just as a
function of investor confidence you know
investors you know they think interest
rates are headed lower they've got more
likely to or cash they're more likely to
sort of you know sort of um you know
being defensive assets and it's less
likely to sort of extend credit and so
you just sort of that's a sort of credit
chain and then we can talk about repos
of us I think this is what's happening
in the repo market as well you know I
think that whole process gets sort of
did okay there's a wrench gets thrown in
that process when the economy slows was
humans start to get nervous at the
margins repos repo Manus and this is my
top my favorite topic right now to me
let's take a step back to repo and then
dive into repo repo is only cool talk
about like once every three four five
six ten years mmhmm yeah they call it
the plumbing of the financial system no
one ever talks about the damn financial
system it's plumbing what were these
pipes going that this is the point of
the global economy the world economy is
a dollar a dollar credit based economy
for better or for us
we can argue to six ways to Sunday if
that's a good thing or bad thing
it's affliction Airy currency that
Federal Reserve with the fractional
reserve system yeah we get all these
those are all secondary considerations
behind this beyond the statement the
global economy is based on largely
denied dollar denominated base credit
and most of global trade is to not only
finance but also settled in US dollars
my theory on that is because you
probably have the biggest guns we assert
the most coercive force around the world
that could change but I'm not making
that call so you take this back to that
was probably the problem in our repo
market the repo at its core is really
just overnight lending its its people
with cash that want to earn a yield on
and sort of Lin on a secured basis to
either repo transactions or you know
sort of money market funds you know
money my friends actually you know
funding to people markets you know it's
people with cash in in terms of the
liquidity and the credit system meets
the demand for credit it's it's that so
when there's less of that cash coming in
for people who need the cash who need
the repo to sort of lever up you know I
think of like big hedge funds a lot a
lot of these big hedge funds you know
sort of rely on repo to sort of grow
their balance sheet you know they they
might have a need for for leverage to
just sort of to the gross up but they
you know they might not necessarily be
an incremental supply of cash and the
reason there's no income and a supply
cache is because of the US dollar is so
strong the federal reserved and in this
happens before every recession the
Federal Reserve takes the benchmark
interest rate for the world's reserve
currency for the currency that all trade
and credit is settled in globally higher
than all the other benchmark interest
rates you know that creates a series of
a ton of distortions is relates to the
you know sort of the supplying to Mambro
credit there's fourteen trillion dollars
of dollar denominated credit
off-balance-sheet like not in the US
that not issued by US on dhamma
domiciled sort of on borrower that
credit has to be financed in dollars
like the banks who issued that credit
that hedge funds the issue that credit
they the issuer insurance pension funds
they shoot at credit they have to
finance in dollars so when the dollar
goes up their ability to finance in
dollars gets curtailed at the margin so
they have to issue FX swaps all these
things and that's draining cash out of
our repo market and it's it's it's this
is this happens every time ahead of a
recession because what it's really
telling you is that monetary policy
settings are too tight
for the liquidity it's creating a supply
and demand imbalance that that that sort
of integral juncture between cash and
credit demand and so should people be
worried about what's going on in the
repo market or if it persists now the
Fed has thrown the I mean I wouldn't
even call the kitchen sink they've
thrown the bus at this this issue there
they've now I saw somebody who recently
put it in BTC terms they said 70 million
BTC yes so it's is hundreds of billions
of dollars now and thrown out now
it's important to call out that's not a
hundred you know hundreds of billions of
dollars of net new capital no that is
some of the capital is being reused
night after night after night yeah so
it's hey we're gonna put you know 50
billion but it's not fifty billion total
it may be some smaller number used you
know total ten billion five times
whatever absolutely absolutely the
balance sheet has growing I'm sort of
cooling this off top my head and I could
be wrong so correct me if I'm wrong in
this I think the balance sheet is
growing about 300 million dollars in the
last four months mm-hmm and it's
scheduled zqe
no technically no cuz I think Huey has a
different intuition let's take a
separate step aside
do we even have to call it QE it is what
it is it's it's the Federal Reserve
growing its balance sheet by sort of
swapping cash swapping the reserves for
short-term assets that are going to
mature they're likely they're likely
gonna be on a path until the foreseeable
future into the doc and really start the
crack so you don't have the necessary
call QE to me qyz is a different dynamic
the the purpose of QE and and the reason
they targeted longer maturities in the
bond market is because they wanted to
compress term premiums they wanted to
basically make bond yields as low as
they possibly could be to stimulate
demand for credit to stimulate demand
for levering up long how so they're
essentially manipulating returns of
various assets in you know in order to
change behavior in the bingo yeah qyz
designed to change behavior whereas this
is really just designed to make sure
this thing works and it's a lot of
there's some technical factors in there
that are unnecessary discuss I think the
reason why the is it QE is it not QE
becomes a conversation point it's cuz
they specifically said it wasn't again
don't forget Jay Paul's not technical
he's not a tech rat he's not amount of
terrorists or anything like that so you
know he's gonna get himself in trouble
he starts talking about these really big
he's an impossible job
I think a very impossible job and quite
frankly I think he's doing a fairly good
job of what they set out to accomplish
which is to extend the economic cycle
you know we're at full employment
we're probably gonna remain at full
employment for longer than we otherwise
would have had the map cut interest
rates had they not also authorized this
sort of repo activity if they hadn't
stepped in really kind of what huge q3
of this year for sure but even there was
some troubling signs I think q4 last
year right all the way up until now so
over the last 12 months or so there's
various ways that they've stepped in for
those that are not watching and just
listening we've got some blood lights
here yeah I'm on my third beer the part
of me Darius
told me he said is this like a formal
thing or is this like a Bud Light yeah
so if they hadn't stepped in and and
acted at all where do you think we would
have been right so it's like we know
what happened because they stepped in
but is that a full-scale recession is
that you know depression is that it
would have been bad but it would have
been that bad like we're where were we
headed before they actually slept so
we're definitely headed towards
recession and we're still headed towards
recession
I would argue that the Fed has bought
itself some time and in months and
quarters just sort of kind of walk this
sort of thing off the plank on a slower
pace but you know the the Fed doesn't
control the business cycle the profit
cycle to me the profit cycles would wag
that this is a dog with the tail that
sometimes being wagged by the fed but
the dog is the business cycle in the
profit cycle in the relationship between
labor and profits you know for 10 years
we've had this very slow sluggish
recovery and what that's done is allow
and and a slow sluggish recovery and we
can go into things that really big topic
we should probably hit on is sort of the
impact of monetary ultra easy monetary
policy to me I think it's deflationary
and but one of the reasons I think it's
deflationary it's because you allow for
industry consolidations you allow for
established players in every market to
get bigger to buy growth to quash
competitiveness so this is one of the
reasons why the economy has grown slower
because it's more debt smaller
businesses are more dynamic and they
grow faster but it's also one of the
reasons why wage pressures have been
relatively subdued relative to what your
traditional economists would have
thought based on the Phillips curve you
know but all those things are still
moving in the direction of you know
economic activity you cannot you know
the
is a cycle maturing it's just looking
much longer than yeah it's working for
it it's taking much longer because of
all these sort of what I would consider
to be deflation or disinflationary sort
of policy stimulus but we're we're kind
of there yet you know if you look at
sort of there's a few things you know I
don't like to talk about charts you know
in podcast format but there's a few data
points that I think a really important
highlight for your listeners you know so
obviously we're you know fifty six year
lows and unemployment data but there's
some cracks underneath the hood in the
labor market that are starting to
suggest that the deterioration we saw in
corporate profits that began in q3 of
this year last quarter is likely to
continue so you got private sector wage
growth that 33.7% that set a cycle high
you have total nonfarm payrolls growth a
one point four seven percent you know
that's trending towards a cycle low at
the end of every business cycle those
things really start to diverge ie
employment growth starts to slow drop
dramatically yes as a way to stay high
and sticky
you know the unit labor cost inflation
is hard to get rid of it's the economic
equivalent of fat yeah right bingo you
actually have to fire people yeah to
reduce your Luna neighbor cost at this
point in the profit site yep that's the
point yeah and and so as you kind of
look at this one of the things that I
think is really interesting is somebody
like a Ray Dalio
right because I think most people are in
LA from him who he just he's seen as a
very kind of traditional guy right in
the sense of markets and kind of how he
views he's very professional etc and
earlier this year he wrote a thing it
said look central banks have two tools
they can cut rates and they can print
money right and they're unlikely to have
the same impact if they do that now as
they historically have had right so last
two recessionary periods cut raids
I think 550 basis points or more we
obviously don't have that much to cut if
they print money we're kind of but it
did a little bit to it and so we're kind
of used to the impact that that can have
and so that impact is softening and his
prediction or kind of thought process
was they're gonna cut rates are gonna
print money and eventually we're gonna
move into a world of modern monetary
theory or this MMT and I don't think he
really took a position on like is it
good or is it bad but more of like it
just is what it is
right like like we're headed in that
direction I think we're already there
okay don't forget that one of the things
that catalyzed
the spike in repo rates in the q3 of
this year was the fact that the
Treasury's um when they when the
Congress authorized this sort of
increase in the debt cimmyt debt limit
it allowed the Treasury to start to
reissue bills again they have a very
heavy bill issuance calendars for the
second half of the year so it started to
drain cash out of the market you know
the Treasury Java the big dog eats first
and this is how finance works so when
the big dogs are draining cash on the
market you know repo already started the
spike in the Fed said oh my god there's
not enough dollars to go around for the
treasurer to get fed for foreign for
foreign commercial banks to get fed you
know for foreign hedge funds to get fed
for our own commercial banks to get fed
you know the ones that aren't you know
there aren't flusher reserves and there
tend to be pretty concentrated so I
think what the Fed is doing is
effectively acknowledging in so many
words that US budget deficits are really
big and they're draining a lot of cash
in the system but what's also draining a
lot of cash to the system is that
foreign international banks commercial
banks and all these different players
they also want to extend assets in
dollars because dollars have the highest
yield so now they're draining cash from
system by FX there's all these different
things happening in around the market
that are a mere function of the Federal
Reserve's monetary policy setting being
too tight for the supply and demand
balance of liquidity and in the NAFTA
credit China also around there love
Chinese China's in a secular slow demand
you know so China's been slowing for 10
consecutive quarters one of the most
important metric we track in the Chinese
economy which is the nominal growth rate
of secondary industries that's that's
that's the China dream that's the
urbanization that's all stuff that kind
of touches that stuff and it's been it
peaked at 14% after the shanghai core
sharing our core was their massive
fiscal monetary stimulus program that we
saw in 15 and 16 mostly through 16 and
led the high as we saw in growth both in
China and globally in 17 they peaked in
q1 of 17 and been slowing ever since you
know they're effectively from a
signalling perspective in terms of their
communication but also from a signaling
respective in terms of their monetary
policy settings they're just managing a
slowdown it's like every six weeks you
hear their pump maybe 200 billion CMI
and in open market operations or you
know the Lin this medium term loan or
whatnot and this is the way the PBOC
managers their liquidity um policy
settings but on a training basis you
know almost coming out of the market at
a hundred billion dollar club a month
you know medium-term them the balance of
the median term lending facilities you
know down 20 to 30 percent year over
year you know they're basically
acknowledging the
fact they can't get the dollars that
they need to grow their credit base so
they're just gonna allow it to slow in
to the dollar breaks until the defects a
dollar with some very aggressive policy
when I'm not sure if we're there yet
well what would that be I think the Fed
has to turn around and say we're either
gonna increase the amount we're going to
start to meet the incremental demand cuz
right now it's like oh here's you know
I'm looking my finger and put it in here
mimicking jpowel here's 60 billion
dollars a month but is it really 6 you
know I don't they really know what the
blues really demanded by the market I
think what would be an incremental heed
of a step is saying we're going to
automatically increase our sort of um
our supply of bank reserves to take out
liquidity from the market or to surprise
and quiddity to the market rather it
commensurate with step ups in demand or
they can actually start to move out of
the maturity curve and say we're
explicitly targeting term premiums we
wanted to you know do so QE thing and
how much demand do you think is unmet
right now oh I don't talk about size
wise you know so I haven't done this
analysis myself so I don't I don't want
to put too much stock in it but I did
see a paper floating around the street
you know clients pushers you email you
know people's research all the time they
kind of want to get our take on it
because we have a very quantitatively
oriented investment framework and we can
talk about that some other time but you
know they want to see you how this meet
you know with it with some of these sort
of key takeaways mean in the context of
our quads so you know I did see a paper
that said there's a a one point four
trillion dollar hole relative to the
amount of sort of dollar base
liabilities that that global commercial
banks have to fund their US dollar
assets relative to the size of the US
dollar assets that are on their balance
sheets Wow so 1.4 trillion is a lot a
lot a lot of liquidity what that's
that's over that's over a hundred
million dollars a month if the Fed has
to supply that yeah well the way I think
about what is that that's two times
right because I think was 700 million
700 ARP yeah Oh awkward what is it what
the hell it's a billion amongst friends
at this point we're talking in troy's
now brother come on this is why by the
way this is why bitcoin exists yeah I
don't know that bitcoin is a tradable
good and we can talk about whether it's
a commodity whether it says currency
whether it's money you know those I
think though I have my views on let's
just go right into Bitcoin
yeah before we go back into Bitcoin
this whole game that they're trying to
keep and we'll go in a Bitcoin this
whole game that they're trying to keep
going this dollar based credit game it's
clearly broken obviously we would have
had a oh wait we wouldn't have had the
sort of political unrest that we see
globally we wouldn't have the sort of
sort of inequality that we see
domestically and globally it's clearly
broken that's my biggest there's
scrambling to maintain this game my
biggest thing is the wealth inequality
that when we break for each into the
quarter we break from the gold reserve
and we basically go into a system where
okay I can print money now what a lot of
people don't understand and it actually
took me it's an education problem right
we don't financially educate young
people as they grow up and they're still
don't have the financial education I
wrote this thing a few weeks ago that
said money is too dangerous of an idea
for school people actually understood
how money works so right it's the Henry
Ford quote right if people understood
banks there be revolution before the
morning yeah absolutely
which is the whole idea of money is that
there's inflation that inflation will
ravage your wealth
if you leave your wealth in dollars so
right and so your people who are
critical intelligent or financially
literate they understand this they get
out of dollars to get into real asset
stocks like what yeah well fifteen
percent of Americans don't understand
that game aren't in a position to play
that game you think it's as high as 50 I
think it's way lower than that oh that
don't understand no no you think you
think the proportion of Americans that
do understand is is fifty percent well
here's the wire right the proportion of
Americans that do understand is
somewhere around 10 to 20 percent that's
probably true I'm giving people the the
the metric I'm using as to get to 50
percent is that fifty percent of
Americans can't afford a four or five
hundred dollar emergency bill so those
are people who for sure are living
paycheck to paycheck yeah everybody have
no cash have no assets this is paycheck
to paycheck in that world those people
or one usually also not they don't
benefit from having a inflation adjusted
wage contract those they're getting paid
their 15 bucks an hour or 10 bucks an
hour every single year urine and you're
out they think they're getting paid the
same obviously not actually because of
inflation but also then they're leaving
all of their savings in cash that cash
is just kidding if they have savings
exactly you can't be balls to the wall
along equities for dollars a weekend you
got to you know pay little
like bill of course and so I think that
that's a world where at the wealth and
equality is so obvious right you can
look at very explicit charts that show
wealth inequalities got away working
chaps my ass more by the way I grew up
very poor - drug addict parents and
evicted probably seven or eight times
lived in a van for two months
yeah one thing chaps my ask more than
the wealth of quality these people are
perpetuating so you're already a Bitcoin
er right whether you know it or not
because the whole idea in my opinion
around Bitcoin today right there's a lot
of people who will say it's a savings
technology right what that basically
means is today we ask people to be
experts at what they do for a living so
you know with your research whether
you're a marketer whether you're a
teacher a fireman
you're just an accountant you know
whatever you do you have to go and be
good at it so you can get paid to make a
living you make that money but then we
ask you not only do you have to be good
at your job we also need you to be a
good investor because we need you to
understand when you get out of the that
cash if you're smart enough to
understand to get out of cash do you go
into equities do you go into gold do you
go into bonds do you go into real estate
do you go into private markets can you
go into private markets where the law is
right all this stuff that it takes to
invest the everyday American has no
[ __ ] clue what's going to air right
it's for asking me go to your job Plus
for asking be a good investor and so
that's where a guy comes in the walls so
one there's professionals who can help
right so some people just say look I
have no clue I'm gonna hand over my
money or the ideas to somebody else the
second thing is that people trying to
actually screw it up yeah right and so
then that way they do they go they
invest in some dumb stuff right and
actually lose their wealth faster and so
what is up happening is well what if
there was a currency that allowed the
world to operate in such that when you
earned your living you could leave your
wealth in that asset that you earned it
in and that asset was not inflated away
was not debased away you know I I'll
push back a little necks I agree I agree
what you're saying what I just nobody
ever comes in here and pushes back I
want some pushback no absolutely and
again it's and it's it's coming from the
respective of someone's who kind of like
not from the sense of someone who's deep
in the knowledge of of crypto Bitcoin
but more just someone who's you know
kind of deep in the knowledge of kind of
how the global economy works
there's Bitcoin can be one of three
things it could be a commodity but you
speculate in and it has a use in an in
use and
and a cost of carry and a cost of
production it could be a currency a
medium of transaction or it could be
money which is supposed to be a store of
value like gold was money for the gold
and silver or money for the vast vast
majority of human history
why do you separate money and currency
because money is a is a medium of
exchange money is how how the how the
person who manufactured this delicious
by light I'm drinking can can get the
stuff that I have that adit so I don't
have to carry gold to to currency
currency anyway the currencies how yet
currencies how I physically transfer my
wealth to him so I can get the purchase
of good or service and and money is my
ability to purchase that good or service
and so I think we'll you separate those
things I mean Bitcoin kind of touches on
all three but the one thing I think that
it has that it doesn't satisfy the money
criteria and then this is my own
personal view at least not yet is the
fact that it's very volatile money at
its core in a somewhat you just told me
about people not wanting to watch their
wealth get inflate it away you cannot
afford if you're making call it a
thousand bucks a week and you know you
have a two-bedroom probably for kids to
have your value your your light bill
your writ go down by fifteen or sixteen
percent in a day or in a week well it
that's not money it's very much a
speculation yeah it's very much so
there's two buckets here one is where
are you in the lifecycle of adoption
like when there's very low levels of
adoption it's much more volatile I
should get more and more adoption it
becomes less volatile we know that it's
becoming less volatile but it's volatile
it is right and the second is there's
definitely various wealth levels as to
how you are affected so if you only have
a thousand dollars you put all thousand
dollars into it and then it fluctuates
30 percent well that's 3 percent of your
wealth Yeah right if instead you put 1
to 5 percent of your wealth right and if
I weighs 30 percent not as much not as
big of a deal because the risk is kind
of contained to a allocation your
portfolio that is for what you would
think as risky assets right so I think a
lot of that is kind of where we are on
the stage of adoption and also who is
participating but quick question yes
what and this is a very dumb question
there on text you know way more about
the macro
than I do I probably know more about
bitcoins probably you're being very
modest you know you're one of the
world's leading experts in boxer Darius
is Satoshi what I don't understand and
this is more just this take me out of
the this don't talk to me about the
white papers also take me to like the
white board explanation of why the price
of Bitcoin changes at all okay so well a
couple of again relatively Elementary or
simplistic things but it's still
important to state I think it's just to
remind people about price
so one price is a function of supply and
demand of course right - is it depends
on what you price the asset in so the
whole idea of Amazon stock
well one Amazon stock equals 1 a.m. as
on stock though we price them in dollars
there's really an anomaly yeah and so
the the dollar value is is moving say
there with Bitcoin right it's the dollar
is priced in dollars so you end up with
one dollar equals one dollar inflation
it's kind of a hidden tax right and so
that that purchasing power is changing
but one dollar equals one dollar with
Bitcoin one dot by the way that goes
back to what I said on the dollar based
credit system one dollar only goes one
dollar because we all agreed to agree to
use this dollar as the basis for the
entire global financial system so
Bitcoin if you live in a Bitcoin world
right I always describe like there's two
financial systems there's an
inflationary fractional reserve system
that's dollar based and that's how we
all know and we bait and we denominated
everything in dollars then there is this
deflationary kind of automated software
driven world that lets say that Bitcoin
is what you're gonna denominator
everything in yeah actually in the
Bitcoin denominator world one Bitcoin he
goes one Bitcoin it has forever just
like one down goes one dollar now where
you see the price volatility is what is
the dollar worth versus Bitcoin and
Bitcoin first the dollars and so there
would be some people who are I'm not
gonna argue this but some people would
argue that the dollar is being devalued
against Bitcoin right now systematically
and over a long period of time sure I'm
all in on that but the price volatility
in dollar terms of it went from a
thousand dollars in you know January
chosen 17 to 20 to 3 to 14 to 7 X I mean
that's a lot of volatility right in
dollar terms and so I think
what ends up happening here is you get
one hyper hyper retail driven markets
historically because there's not a lot
of electronic trading there's not a lot
of the structures that are in place in
in kind of Wall Street yeah in terms of
smoothing prices right they can't stop
market and valuation based frameworks
all this stuff right so you have a
relatively small amount of people who
hold an asset it's very human driven and
so also I never gets excited price
shoots up all of a sudden one gets
really scared right price goes down a
lot so that's one aspect of it the
second is like the price discovery of
this thing is it's kind of natural right
if you think about it hey there's this
new asset it's ten years old people are
trying to figure out what is it worth
hey gold we pretty much know right we
gold over a 10-year period it's
basically not moved right it's kind of
yeah this had fluctuations in between
but for the most part it's been like
dead money for about ten years we look
at Bitcoin over ten years it went from
$1 to $90,000 in the last decade right I
mean nuts in terms of if you put one
dollar in and what's worth today right
so you put you bought $1 a Bitcoin ten
years ago today that $1 worth $90,000
right huge in terms of price
appreciation right or Quinn appreciation
in dollar terms but it's all because
people are trying to figure out what is
Bitcoin worth totally right and I don't
think anyone has an answer yet now the
one thing that I do think is really
interesting is so we go back to what's
happening in repo markets and Federal
Reserve's and demand it'll quiddity all
stuff we don't actually know exactly
what they're doing from us apply like I
you or I couldn't tell anyone
how much dollars is being printed today
right now we can we can look at bank
assets and we can kind of triangulate or
man we don't know an exact number with a
hundred percent certainty rehydrate
emphasizing three-month t-bills
no one knows no one knows that's right
that's why the Fed is flying in the dark
yes
second is I'll even give you a better
stat I forget the exact math my partner
mark knows it but there's like the Fed
has been trying to guess the next
quarters GDP for like 248 times or
something they'd never got it right
Ilana fat which was the the biggest sort
of advent and then Federal Reserve
history this is this changed the way we
think about forecasts but it was now
kasa thing and by the way you know we've
someone some of their ideas in terms of
developing our own outcasts which are
far more accurate the line of feds now
caste and mind you I have a lot respect
with you they're really smart people
they have a they have a intra quarter
tracking error of two hundred forty
basis points and a number that can
basically be zero to 300 basis points
it's crazy
it literally this quarter on November
13th their Atlanta fat tracker went to
zero point three six percent now it's
two point three six percent like that if
as an investor I mean maybe that's great
if you're an economist and you know yeah
usually comes that is [ __ ] for an
investor on vanity yeah you can't we're
drinking beers you literally Bud Lights
sorry alright so here's the conference
if we don't know the supply of dollars
right we can guess and get close but we
don't know for sure and then we don't
know demand either so there's a bunch of
models that let's model supply and let's
model demand Oh basically what we're
doing is we're guesstimating on both of
those things and we come out with price
right or what the output of that
equation is so supply the man we end up
with a result with Bitcoin we know with
100% certainty one side of that equation
so we know supply today 1800 Bitcoin
were created and put out into
circulation that previously were not in
circulation that happens every single
day for four years in May 2020 it's
gonna get cut from one hundred one
thousand eight hundred to nine hundred
right
it says supply schedule is known as
transparent predictable when you add in
the fact that if I can know 100%
certainty the supply schedule of the
currency now I just have to worry about
modeling the demand side right so
thinking about the future value of
something well let's say that you and I
are really bad we're just as bad as the
economists the Federal Reserve etc and
all we say is we're gonna be super
simplistic about it we're simply gonna
take the rate of demand that has
occurred for the last 11 years and we're
gonna extrapolate it out with no great
change so no increase no decrease we're
just gonna say it stays the same we
could be wrong on that let just saying
that as you do that what ends up
happening is because you know the supply
with a hundred percent certainty and you
just extrapolate out what you get is a
continued increase in dollar terms of
the value of Bitcoin because
artificially supplied asset demand
increases well the US dollar value is
gonna go up so and so I think this is
where you
see folks into like the macro economy
world right they're too smart
like I'm convinced that most of them
they're like it can't be that easy there
are lots more than I like it can't be
that easy but if you go back to just the
pure basics of supply and demand early
what occurs is that's the value right
and this is the key piece the value is
pretty well-documented in terms of a lot
of these models and stuff because you
have one input they know with hundred
percent certainty you can just
extrapolate them in turn the price is
what's volatile the price is volatile
and the price is quoted in the unit of
something else yes and this to me is the
fundamental I don't want to use the word
issue because it's the issue it's not
flawed I'm looking for a more elegant
word and this is the fundamental problem
that Bitcoin and crypto in general still
need to solve with you if you you either
in this two problems one you have to
decide whether or not you're trying to
usurp the dollar based credit system or
you want to compete alongside the dollar
based credit system pick pick your
poison if you want to usurp the dollar
based credit system then you can no
longer quote your price in dollars for
obvious reasons so I think that this is
the biggest difference between Wall
Street and the hardcore bitcoiners the
hardcore bitcoiners are denominating
things in Satoshi's which is the
smallest unit right that's like you know
ponies or whatever or BTC yeah the
finance I want to put it in a in
portfolio with a bunch of other assets
yeah and so what's interesting and I
don't have an answer for this can it be
both can insert well here can it serve
one purpose for one community and
another community basically takes that
same asset that's serving that purpose
in the Bitcoin world and then dollar to
nominate it and have it served a purpose
for them as well mm-hm
I actually think it can what I don't
know is how does that perform in that
markets how does that perform in these
other economic type cycles not just the
longest bull market in history where is
the every assets going up into the right
just because you know we're printing
things to them oh well and also you know
like walk let's let's play it thought
you gave me thought expand let's play
thought experiment where the dollar is
no longer the asset that settles global
trade
that settles global credit but also by
the way it's probably somewhere between
500 and a trillion 500 billion a
trillion dollars in global Desrosiers
yeah oh yeah if the dollar gets replaced
by anything I don't care if it's Bitcoin
empty cans about light if anything there
will be chaos they'd be Wars
they'll be death mmm there'll be people
scrambling to replace the system
there'll be big guns and tanks and
nuclear bomb this is the problem with in
my opinion I don't want to use the word
problems I think there's an elegant
solution here that is well above my
paygrade
but if you want to usurp the dial based
credit system you got a hell of a lot of
hay to mill and a lot of really angry
people a lot of big guns so you're
essentially taking away the power taking
away the power of government yeah
they don't they don't have they have a
vested interest in remaining in power so
this is this is where you get deeper
down the Bitcoin rabbit hole right which
is this is topical well so there's two
components that I think most bitcoiners
either one believe or think is a higher
likelihood chance than people would
admit so not necessarily saying it's a
90% chance but just saying let's say
everyone thinks that this is a 1% chance
and they think it's five percent right
or what a chance here let me say what it
is so the first is the separation of
state and money mm-hmm so exactly you're
talking about right yeah the state the
one of the most powerful weapons it has
is the fact that they control and throw
the currency but even more so the United
States controls the global reserve
currency right we've done a fantastic
job of weaponizing in all this stuff
yeah we did there's also a lot of noise
internationally that he want to get away
from the dollar based system the look
whether it's Russia China Iran today was
talking about it exception right good
look you know who the world's I don't
wanna pay off the emerging market
world's largest dollar denominated let
Boris these guys can't get they can't
get off the system yeah yeah well well
so that's one piece of it is this
separation of state money the second
piece of it though is every global
currency yeah we're just gonna go
through all my 30s on a sports I'm on my
fourth he's on a Serbia is every global
reserve currency that has failed has
failed for one of two reasons it was the
based away or there was conflict and
they try to extend ourselves well and
somebody else basically you know your
country has all of the power because you
have the currency I come in I basically
kill all of your people now I'm in
charge cuz I'm the most military power
you know highest military power you know
I put yeah now I put my currency in
place so the basing the currency every
country in the in the world today
is already doing that right now they're
doing it in a very controlled manner
right it's all these things but every
single currency that is a fiat currency
is being debased away so that's kind of
the countries are doing it to themselves
they're eating themselves alive in a
very slow manner that could last
hundreds of years right by the way one
quick thing inelegant keep going it's
impossible to run a fractional reserve
banking system and not perpetually
debase of course you wondering exactly
when mature incredibly you need
somewhere to put the new money you need
inflation you need a growth because
there are more people coming down the
pike there are more people with needs
and demands for homes and demands for
goods and services this is that that big
once you start that one said the can I
on the worms or the worms out of the can
you can't with a mecca absolutely so
that's one piece of it the second piece
though is and this was a thought I had
about I don't know six months ago
whatever I wrote it in the physical
world the most powerful military has the
most guns the most soldiers the most you
know the best airplanes the best ships
all stuff in the digital world the best
offense is the best defense yeah so what
I mean by that is if I get in if i hack
you where you're another country I'm an
adversary i hack into your electrical
grid your nuclear system whatever you
essentially are under attack until you
kick me out yeah right now you can
attack me but if you can't get in yeah
I'm the most powerful right if I get in
and you kick me out then again you can
retain power as long as you keep me out
so if defense is the best offense in the
digital world this most or the strongest
computing network in the world is
Bitcoin it has more computing power
securing that one network and all other
competing networks that exist so there's
nothing more can I can i push back on
that a little bit because one of the
things I thought is so fascinating about
corn is just the sort of the energy
intensity it takes to mind BIC yep if
you cut off Bitcoin power supply so this
is when as you get into this right what
you realize is okay there's a ton of
computing power that securing it very
provable in terms of it it's nearly
impossible you did not like human
capital what about the tricity know the
machines so there's more computing power
beating the machines that is securing
that network than any other computing
network in the world so you could spend
billions of dollars if you're the United
States China whatever you can't hack
this as well when I cut off your natural
gas supply okay you've sowed your light
so because and this is the key piece of
Bitcoin you couldn't not I yeah you
couldn't do this any other way than the
way that it grew it's so decentralized
meaning that there's so much computing
power in each area of the world right
there's no one attacked cornish off all
electricity the united states we don't
know who's minding who's not have to do
that we're gonna target large-scale
mining or large coal if you cut off
everyone in the United States Bitcoin
would continue running right now let's
say the two countries said hey we're
gonna do it so I say you liars
unprecedented global coordination and
you would never hear that for me it's
nearly impossible right you already have
the two largest geopolitical powers in
the world beefing and they're gonna keep
beefing intial even if they agreed to
coordinate along with a bunch of other
countries but Quinette was right you
know what I think they're going to do
what and market market for new house
really thoughtful in this topic I'm sort
of sourcing something it is that is
governments are really good at playing
copycat if this if this [ __ ] works
they're gonna they're gonna want well
they're gonna take all the greenbacks
out of my wallet out of your wallet
they're gonna transition them to a
digital currency and they're you know
I'm not sure who's technology they're
gonna steal or if they're gonna you know
unless you know CIA types and to create
this but we're moving in the path of
Federal Reserve wanting full control
over the quantity and price of money
right now they have partial control over
both yep well and this is I think where
there's this guy Alex glass you know
sending bunch of his stuff so he's the
chief strategy officer of the human
rights foundation right and so his life
has pretty much been dedicated to what
you and I would consider more
philanthropic and kind of socio-economic
issues except for but in foreign
countries so things around freedom of
speech independent
it's self sovereignty etc but not here
the United States for the most part
usually somewhere else he's brought up
the point which i think is a very valid
point which is as these countries go and
move to digital currencies pretty much
every country the world's talking about
these central back digital currencies
right they they want to create a digital
currency same monetary policy they're in
control they can print they can remove
the crooks making the policy settings
what it does is it drastically increases
their surveillance capabilities of
course there's a point where you take
cash out of the system now I know
everything is I increase my tax revenue
all this they're very incentivized to do
this both and so when that happens
bitcoin is the only digital currency
that has the pseudonymity rather than
how you use it and has the security to
withstand state-level attacks and is not
geographically constrained in terms of
centralization and etc and so what its
gonna do is it's gonna be the only way
that people can opt-out use digital
money without providing the surveillance
capabilities to the state so I
completely agree with that and and this
this is cool you were talking we're
digging down to like Revelation Bible
terms in like this this is it's called
the mark of the beast and and I
genuinely believe in my brother's a
publican scholar or at least now he is
my dream you believe and I wanna get too
far into stuff because I was like a
heretic but there's going to be a mark
of the beast and and I genuinely believe
that it's going to be a centralized
currency or a series of centralized
currencies where you can only transact
you can only be quote unquote
on the grid in a centralized currency
and something like Bitcoin will allow
people who defect from that grid to not
to sort of stay remain a separation of
state dhoni but but don't forget when
you denied the mark of the beast it says
in the Bible you deny your access to
food you deny your access to education
your access to shelter you're basically
choosing to live in the wilderness just
so you can quote-unquote maintain your
purchasing power mm-hmm I don't know how
many people are going to choose that do
that and by the way this is written in
the Bible that may be the fairest
argument against Bitcoin right so people
always ask me two questions what's the
best argument against it what's the most
likely reason why in mind you I'm not
arguing against big day yeah I'm just
jokin but what's the best argument
against it is actually Bitcoin does
exactly what people think it's gonna do
and nobody cares or
it's too inconvenient right so basically
even though it's better technology
football stuff just to give me a people
don't care right they're not gonna
change they can't they can't mentally
shift from dollars to BTC you know I
don't mental Jeff I think you can't
there's gonna get any point where you
can't physically shift well if you want
to maintain your status quo
it is popular your your your status quo
that's being eroded by inflation yeah
it's definitely possible so that's one
two is what is the most likely cause
that it fails it's actually a
self-inflicted wound well so the
developers end up creating some kind of
bug etc right that could fail to me
that's the biggest risk it's not state
level attacks also other kind of stuff
it's just somebody makes a mistake right
now the beauty is that the process is
pretty thorough right and and quite
extensive in terms of reviewing code etc
and so it's unlikely that it happens but
to me that's like the biggest issue like
I wouldn't use the word fail like
everything has an issue right like we're
humans and then today we're talking
about measuring and I think this is the
most valuable part of money and that I
don't think Bitcoin touches on tus tile
touches I don't think any of these
things touch I think the only thing that
really touches this is probably
something that you can physically I'm
not a gold bug at all but I do think
it's got to be something that we all
have agreed to agree on for thousands of
years that this is some value and this
is why I think gold is probably the
purest form of money is because money is
really just a unit of human time I'm
basically your main water oh yeah I'm
out I'm not I'm not
I knew these things I I need to do more
research to figure out what I think I
want to be in long term but I think
there's a reason for all of these things
in your portfolio and I don't want to
say portfolio like I'm trying to best
this yeah I want to say like in your
life portfolio yep like you need like
when I when I when I when I pay someone
for something it's not because I I
wanted it's because I'm acknowledging
that it took him time of his you know
his perpetual human life that will
eventually end to create this good or
the service so the a nice transitioning
some of my time for some of his time so
the best thing that I've told people
that gets them immediately to realize
that Bitcoin has value is one currency
which is the dollar is inflationary in
nature and so it promotes consumption
yeah right
get out of this buy things bikes totally
when you go to a deflationary structure
right with a disinflationary monterrey
schedule all of a sudden you're
incentivized to save yeah you're you're
incentivized my time is very valuable
Tom's done a me this and I'm gonna hold
this right cuz that's how valuable time
is and I think that mindset shift is
really really hard for Americans right
just cuz it's consume consume consume
yeah but also it's driven by the dollar
right in the sugar there so I think look
you're gonna do more research we're
going we're gonna bring you back and
you're gonna be a full-bore Bitcoin er
because I could already tell you you
think a lot of the same things that
bitcoiners think I think those I haven't
spent the time yeah yeah race week to be
frank I mean I thought about I'm not a
conspiracy theorist at heart who do you
think Satoshi is then Bitcoin is I mean
I know who that is supposed to be I
don't know that we know who he is
okay I think I think it's a concept to
be totally oxidant yeah he's probably
group of people I think it's it's it's
supposed to represent like hey man stay
looking for me I don't exist that's the
[ __ ] point
Marty bent is a guy in the Bitcoin world
and he he just work at barstool sports
cool dude and and he calls the
Immaculate Conception yeah right it's
the it's a religion money's a religion
right oh this is religion I haven't I'm
wearing a Cruz I'm wearing a gold chain
and the reason I wore the I'm wearing a
gold chain it's because when I grow up
when I grew up all the people that had
societal value to me were gold change
and these are rappers these are athletes
you know I'm unfortunately not from the
kind of communities that you know
thought people like Bill Gates or people
like Jeff Bezos hats Idol value I didn't
know those people were I didn't have the
internet you know so to me that that is
what's what's valuable to me but value
is a is a transferable is a it's a
transferable concept and it's a
non-transferable concept you know what I
mean by that is you can pay someone
money to do something for your currency
to do something for you but also what's
also valuable to me is like you know
like I have a you know a letter for my
girlfriend you know that's only valuable
to me so you you'll love this one of the
things that I'm fascinated by is the
cultural icons that you and I grew up
with we're about the same age and yeah I
remember like very distinct moments and
growing up so the first is
when jay-z's Big Pimpin came out and all
my video on the on the yacht right with
the girls I got a lot of you two days
ago in the shower after the gym I sort
of was mimicking jay-z's dancing when
the Sun came on miles in the shower in
the shower not getting this two days ago
by the way so we yes we share a lot of
right so it was a big moment
the second was Nellie country grammar
yep and you just heard that that okay
who's available chick in the room you
the third was first time I ever skipped
school in high school
Carter to Lowell Wayne came out Mike my
buddy was like hey man Carter to come
else like what's that he's like this is
fire CD I was like I'm there and we went
in skip school we bought it so those
guys right who were these like cultural
icons right Allen Iverson all stuff now
what's happened yeah I even told Michael
Jordan like all these guys it for our
air this our we're so there's a earlier
mid-thirties there's there's a very
direct line in the sand where half of
them made horrible financial decisions
right if you look at Allen Iverson Lil
Wayne always because they didn't have
any coaches zero grew up in these
communities there's no one saying money
it's not even about how I spend money
it's I literally don't know how to
invest mine I don't know how to open a
mortgage I start a mortgage and I open
an investment account I don't even know
who to call if I want to [ __ ] buy the
stock market so literally a lack of
resources in education take those guys
and on the other side of the line puffy
jay-z right all these guys who JC's a
billionaire know what the difference is
between them what surround themselves
are really intelligent people absolutely
they one of my favorite things is that
jay-z and LeBron James both when they
forgot first hit it called up Warren
Buffett it's a guy I need to come see
you you're supposed to be the smartest
guy in the world on this thing tell me
tell me what to do difference LeBron
James 18 year old kid who who by the way
to me legend he never got that's my
point right like 18 years old he was 16
I think and he was on the sit on the
Sports Illustrated covered the chosen
one all stuff from 16 years old till
today he's played in the NBA now for
72 most members ever right the dude
you've never heard Affairs fraud no
taxes worst thing you can hear on is
that he's too nice of a teammate this
guy JR Smith get the ball in the NBA
Finals like this that's the worst end so
carry on but that's the again I agree
your point and so when you look at that
that's somebody who by the way girl with
a single mother yep right I actually
think the last scandal he was involved
in was when he was in high school he
somehow got like memory got with the to
Mitchell and s jerseys and like a Hummer
or something there was something that
happened and Olson was freaking out and
so what'd he do he just said just take
it back like I did you know whatever if
getting stuff for freezes scandal then
who all these like and I want to be I'm
not I'm gonna be gender bias anything
there's a lot of people who are much
younger than me who clearly don't work
and earn the same level of income that
people like you and I make and leave it
in our buildings I'm like how do you
live here yeah I don't mean like they
shouldn't live there I mean like
somebody's paying your rent and this is
very New York City things but is so my
favorite by far is the individuals that
at Ohio State mm-hmm took their their
cleats that they owned in there and sold
them hey guy travel for it own the
tattoo thing I'm friends the guy who
shop I can't get a tenant so my uncle
can put a hundred thousand dollars in
stocks in my portfolio and that's fine
but if I get a tattoo you know it's
institutionalized racism we don't need
to go on a tangent on that that's what
this I am there's two things that are
happening in the world right now but I'm
incredibly happy over the last six
months to come out one then see
doughboys gonna allow athletes to start
making money off their like mother like
this yep so you can't get paid to play
but I can go and I can go put my face on
a poster we don't solve it whatever so
look you want to be famous be famous
right and get paid that way but don't
get paid to play I grew that second
thing is the SEC is looking at opening
up the accreditation laws to allow more
people to participate in the private
markets say that again the SC DS SEC is
so so you know
we have to be an accredited Wester to do
private do you're gonna change they
define accredited investor like blower
there are shoulder from a million so
that would be part of it we'll see if
they do that or not the biggest pieces
that it'll be education based I agree
take a test I've yet to meet somebody
who doesn't agree with that yeah totally
just take tests just take it does if you
have no by the way no one's gonna want
your thirty bucks okay private you know
like they're not gonna want it but if
you can if they actually want you can
crowdsource thirty dollars at a time you
can you and I can go on Twitter and
raise two million dollars tomorrow if we
needed to so I wrote a thing literally
today that basically says accreditation
is violating the American dream end is
discriminating against millions of
Americans based on wealth its definition
but some I guess who writes still tax
code its Congress everybody in Congress
is a millionaire binding Congress is a
vested interest in keeping the game
going they all wrote books none of them
did insider true no yeah of course all
right listen before we wrap this thing
up I gotta ask you aliens and dinosaurs
what's up believer non-believer oh yeah
I definitely believe in dinosaurs I
don't think dinosaurs all right so
here's my question on dinosaurs every
dinosaur you and I have ever seen pretty
much look the same so when they say
pterodactyl we know what that looks like
t-rex we know what that looks like those
are renditions I disagree they look the
same I think I think the I think what we
saw no we've both seen the same model of
what they tell us they look like yeah
yeah I disagree that the model is
accurate okay I'm saying so my big
question is and I saw this meme on the
internet now I'm fascinated with it you
think that the dinosaurs had hair like
hair like you or I in terms of every
dinosaur you've ever seen
let them have like mullets or or long
hair or anything they think about a
dinosaur you see that had hair probably
yeah alright I'm four beers deep here
answering this just yeah that's fine a
caveat oh but what's the Bud Light
answer did dinosaurs have hair okay so
yes dinosaurs def Linksys because we
have the technology to sort of date
carbon and things of that nature so I
agree with that but again these are
written like when I was a nice click
rocks there's a little kid you know I I
mean I'm telling when I said was poor it
I was very poor we didn't have anything
going on at home you know I would
literally go outside when I was like
five to ten years old
and just find cool rocks rocks I thought
would quite know [ __ ] about them you
couldn't look them up internet there's
no internet back then at least not for
us but when you could you grab things
out of the ground it's not like a just a
one dinosaur as perfectly his bones are
perfectly preserved in the position it
died in there's thousands if not
millions of years ago you got to get two
or three bones most as an archaeologist
you have to frickin imagine what goes
where what it's supposed to look like
these are all renditions based on
artists and archaeologists and their
imagination so give them some credit for
trying but don't necessarily say that's
what a goddamn Tyrannosaurus Rex looked
like we don't [ __ ] know the New York
Post had an article the other day that
basically said there's wide held belief
in the scientific community that
dinosaurs became extinct because
asteroids hit the earth so there's this
big like asteroid impact in a bunch of
dynasty that's false well that's what
science believes so what the New York
Post wrote an article which by the way
credits a New York Post for doing
hard-hitting journalism on the side they
found a report of occasion that
basically said now there's this study
that shows there was a very large
volcanic eruption and there was
increased mercury mercury levels which
they believed actually was lead to the
extinction of dinosaurs before the
asteroid hit and so they basically were
called [ __ ] on the science community
which I found quite funny be they're
both wrong and everybody knows in their
essay the reason that wrong is not
because that's not what the actual
occurrence was it's because no one
[ __ ] knows it's like don't present
anything is fine this is one thing that
we were you know to take this back to
finance and we're not and I mean out in
with that question is I have a secondary
question for you and it so we're still
talking alien so we're salarians out but
before we could truly conclude okay
but no one knows manda that the biggest
issue with with with what's going on and
I think what the coolest thing about
Bitcoin crypto and the information area
that we live in now which is 1020 years
old it's that information is
decentralized now not just currency and
and current money and commodities is
information think about where I am if I
graduated with what I knew coming out of
college in 1989 I would be a freaking
janitor do you know how much statistics
and advanced theories on my career
theory I've taught myself just watching
YouTube videos just reading you twice
versus reading you know - it's the
Betty's I I probably have the equivalent
of a multiple PhDs in economics and
statistics and it's not because I'm a
journalist things at Yale it's because
there's information is now ubiquitous
and I can go learn it and I can teach
myself and learn in my own pace for the
last ten and a half years do people get
mad if we both together put YouTube PhD
in our Twitter BIOS I am one of those
YouTube PC's and I'm proud of ya I'm
absolutely proud of it it's a starter
it's actually helped me since you helped
me if I actually graduated from Yale
knowing everything I should have
remembered from economics and ivory
tower or macro ap macro and micro Pete
you know gobbly [ __ ] that they preach I
would be [ __ ] terrible investing
these people who don't understand how
the row or works in a second other
models work yeah and that's a very
different thing so I'm actually quite
blessed of growing up in this
information age and if any sort of self
taught myself the [ __ ] that actually
matters first there's only so much stuff
that actually matters that's one of the
the great contributions Ray Dalio was
made to our industries they hey man you
guys are looking at all this crap you're
all being macro tours but these things
actually matter I couldn't agree more
speaking of things that matter aliens
real or not again this is one of the
things we can't we have no empirical
evidence to prove so the concept of real
needs to be massaged a bit right
they're real so much - they're real in
the sense that if people believe they
exist they exist because all this is
there intelligent life outside of Earth
uh I'm very religious so I believe you
know if God's not on earth and yes but
again that's that we don't talk about
religion here let's go back into a more
sort of existential concept something is
only real in the human sense if a human
can observe it and/or believe it agreed
if if a human being can observe and/or
believe it or or external takes the
other way around if human being can
observe it and or believes it then it is
real because there's no other plane we
only live in this dimension yeah it's
our it's not respective we're we're
doing hearing touching tasting feeling
things if we're if there's no other
playing where something can exist that
we're not touching him with all those
senses so to answer your question yes
everything that people say is real that
they truly believe is real is real but
it doesn't necessarily mean you can
observe it empirically yes you have to
separate what you're basically talking
about is if aliens were invisible and
they were all around us but no one ever
realized that there's no scientific
proof of it accessible you just have to
find out what you mean by real is it
real because someone believes it or is
it real because there's an empirical
evidence do you believe that there's
intelligent life outside of Earth other
would wouldn't I believe it because
other people believe it but I don't
personally believe it so obviously no
empirical evidence I believe aliens if
sorry-sorry took takes back
I believe aliens exist because other
people believe aliens exist not because
you believe on the puzzle in the mental
image of aliens they're force-feeding
like yes there's no other plane to
discuss we only live in this universe
will there's nothing if someone in this
universe thinks aliens exist then we
have to acknowledge a tail is exist
because we're talking about it right now
are we aliens doing it every day you and
I are by aliens right now so the reason
why this question I asked every podcast
episode is because one day I was laying
in bed and I was like [ __ ] you think
aliens got pets randomly and I turned
the plane and I said hey pet she's like
go to sleep I like congrat enough know
you guys old enough she posted on
Twitter but just got engaged to
beautiful woman awesome woman I don't
know how the hell she puts up with you
but absolutely no arias is he seen me at
my worst and at my best she's winning in
this relationship for sure actually I'm
winning by uh by sure but she she makes
you better see I was laying there and I
was like you know what aliens everyone
always looks at them as one type of
homogenious
species right and independency all these
movies right why don't they have pets I
bet you they have pets like or is there
not like a multi species type I think
people are it is uncomfortable drawing
alien pets because in that by definition
you now making the choice of food who or
what type of a chose given you the size
we're not we're in the 2009 posts oh
nine era where you can barely say I
drink but light and not having people
come at you on Twitter I mean like if
you believe aliens have pets then you
are some your your now making a decision
of what type of alien or what type of
being is an alien pet and now you're
talking about discrimination all these
other things like mind you I'm a black
dude from the hood like few people in
the world have been discriminated
against me more than I have certainly in
this country I get the discrimination
thing but let's lighten up a bit folks I
mean Jesus Christ like your check your
emotions at the door and let's learn how
to make money to you I I'm a really big
believer and what they call Bud Light
politics mm-hmm and one light politics
is basically if you think you disagree
with somebody you have to drink three
Bud Lights with them before you can
agree that you disagree with each other
I love that that's a good and so
literally if you go and drink three Bud
Lights with somebody and you walk away
saying we still disagree with each other
then you actually disagree what like I
don't know 20 30 50 percent of people it
would actually find out they disagree
just don't hurt anybody my sing my head
that's a great idea yet I don't even
necessarily believe it believe in the
Golden Rule like like like just just do
whatever that yo my man let my man cook
my man you can cook as long as you're
not hurting anyone
yep and I think the concept of pain and
hurt are fairly universal well I don't
think we need to go too far into
defining those just don't hurt anybody
if you want to do some weird creepy
stuff or do this or that just let people
cook man China China let the people in
was it wushan was named the province oh
yeah I don't know the Muslims cook
brother oh yeah people Hong Kong cook
let him cook and I heard you you're
still in control let him do it
everything yeah all right so before we
wrap up I'm now B we got podcast so see
this Marius had a podcast he'd be top
ten in the world easy I probably would
also get fired by all my clients very
very loose filter as you can tell by
this my consumption
[Laughter]
I I Drive better three to four beers
deep my light specifically okay I I
invest better one or two Bud Lights deep
because I'm less gun-shy what else do I
do I do with some other quote wink wink
things better when I'm six to eight but
like the podcast podcast absolutely
alright so this is my favorite question
I like the ex people certainly and and I
think you would be one of the best
people out there in in our in our in our
respective communities in our sort of
code join community because you you
understand hip-hop in the culture all
right you know if you had to design a
Mount Rushmore of hip-hop who do you put
on it how many people do I get it for
Mount Rushmore no or no A's and B's no
extra guy no no one a no just a group
count as one a group can count as one
I'll give you that
man yes or no it's not hard at all NWA
biggie Tupac and Lil Wayne wow that is
the quickest response and by the way
honorable mention jay-z could switch
with Lil Wayne in my wow that is ladies
and gentleman I've asked this question
to dozens of people and I have never
ever had anyone respond in under three
to five minutes there's usually a
two-minute pause like oh man this is art
alright so let me explain NWA greatest
group of all time anyone who says it
will fight disagree with Biggie and
Tupac is probably the greatest rivalry
ever and they had the perfect
combination of entertainment the like
kind of lyrics and kind of just their
mastery of the poetic aspects of rap and
then you add in kind of the violent
components the coast etc just like
that's exposing via it's probably just
like the Golden Age of hip-hop right so
you get those three Lil Wayne I put up
there because Lowell Wayne was probably
the first guy at least of my generation
who really took what was more of kind of
a raw underground
pop type community and pulled it into
what we consider like the pop world
today a writer or kind of the socially
acceptable world today so NWA was the
first time that there was like like
somewhat crossover I think into you had
like white dudes who didn't live in the
hood who were running around you know
singing NWA lyrics eminem and lo Lane
are probably the two that started to
pull it jay-z's just the [ __ ] goat
though like some when you put those up
there holding it to force pretty hard
because you can very quickly spider into
all these other ones but I gotta go with
NWA because I think they're the best
ever Tupac and Biggie as just a duo that
coexisted in a world where like we'll
never see that again in our lifetime
because the thing also was at that time
when they said y'all I'm gonna shoot you
like 80% probability they were serious
yeah we're not glorifying violence this
is America folks people go to the movies
to watch I'm using ocean air my day but
like people to movies to watch violence
hip-hop is a depiction of violence that
America craves UFC boxing football yeah
it's the same depiction of violence just
in a lyrical art form musical Arthur
hip hop is a mirror of society and
people don't like looking in the mirror
so what ends up happening is if you look
at all especially the first three right
so if you look at NWA Biggie and Tupac
they weren't making stuff up it was
literally just they were just it was
they were literally as crazy using about
their day was truth right it was hey
this happened yesterday or this happened
yet you know a week ago whatever and
what ended up happening was that really
resonated cuz this raw authenticity and
so if you think about that those are
like earlier days of hip-hop it's very
different than today where I think it's
more of people have figured out like the
algorithm right they realize like okay
here's the type of music I make here's
the beats that I need to use here's how
we're gonna distribute it etc as it's go
viral yeah music in general is a science
now yeah and so I think that but it's
also why you see guys like I don't know
chance the rapper right and some of
these guys did you watch what's the
Netflix documentary that came out
recently on just probably no because I
don't watch TV but I
who is the dude who's dating one of the
Kardashians no it's not Kanye is a West
West world or whatever Travis Scott yeah
that is the way I want Elvis so Travis
Scott basically he's very similar in
that like it's just uh go in the corner
right so you want to Oh fun fact yep
I talked to a very well-known producer
recently a music producer and we were
talking about something and he goes oh
man make it in music so we see today I
go what do you mean he goes dude this is
what I do I send beats the people they
literally like are on their tour bus or
they go in the bathroom at like a rest
stop or something and they record the
lyrics on their phone like literally go
to like voice oh my god
email it to him and he takes that voice
recording and then mashes it up and
there's so much technology change you
know and I said excuse me and he goes oh
yeah dude I could just hit up three
dudes and be like yo give me a give me a
verse here's the beat and literally
there's recorded on their phones and
send it to him in he can mix it all up
and you got a song that nobody ever saw
each other so literally everyone was in
different locations they just send on
the file and just as quickly interject
what you're talking about is the the
information age technology age it is
just quicker and easier to do everything
that human beings used to the toil and
struggle over so guess what
to me that's deflationary things to
change that unit of time for I'm gonna
end with you okay so I know you thought
about oh I definitely thought about this
I this to me it's one of the coolest
discussion topics out there and
hopefully it starts a good debate on
Twitter hey I think I think if to decide
what your Mount Rushmore is and so I
don't know I'll be quick if this I was
just my Rushmore are the people who were
the four most relevant people in hip-hop
but not necessarily for most roman
people and hip-hop according to one
generation because I do think I do think
now that we're seeing guys like jay-z
turned 50 and we're seeing Diddy and
jay-z be billionaires we have to
acknowledge that on the other side of
that there's a whole community of people
that are 14
15:16 that are listening to hip-hop and
have no freaking clue where those 99
bricks went or 96 brits way you know
that's the jay-z and they don't even
know the lyrics are where they were buts
anyway my point is our C project Marcy
projects Marcy even projects it's
probably like a nice community that's
why I've been in my neighborhood it's ya
know the not to digress anyway so jay-z
obviously yep jay-z was huge in the 90s
arguably one of the two three best
lyricist ever in hip hop in terms of to
raw talent the most raw talent at MC
second-most raw talent and she's next
one's the most rough talented jay-z the
most raw talent see he didn't write
anything down he was very unique in that
sense that he can come in and there's
many savage there's many recollections
of him like one day when Hammond cam did
welcome to York City he said Jack
Cameron said quote jay-z walked in there
heard the beat in the six minutes he was
walking on a studio he laid down in a
hole one of the most classic hip-hop
songs of all time in six minutes just
thinking in his head and spree style so
I know you didn't listen to the episodes
I gotta tell you so the music producer I
was talking to his Ryan Leslie
oh yeah grammy-nominated we're talk
about something else yeah but he came in
he did an episode he told me a story
about jay-z so he was one of the
producers on the jay-z Kanye album right
and they were in Australia and while
they're in Australia jay-z woke up he
did with like The Oprah Show or
something in the Sydney Opera House and
he when he took Beyonce I'm like you
know to some location they did whatever
goes through the whole day they have
dinner all stuff start recording music
it's Ryan Leslie as a producer jay-z as
the artist and there's an audio engineer
sitting in the living room in this house
they rented in Australia it's 3 o'clock
in the morning and jay-z's just going
hard-hard [ __ ] awesome and all a sudden
he stands up and he throws his
headphones off fingers who the [ __ ] is
gonna catch me who's gonna catch me I'm
jay-z yeah and look what I'm doing now
yeah and the whole thing was it didn't
matter how much better he was and
everybody he was still hungry and he is
and this is 10 years ago 12 years ago
now right and you know to have some
chosen 8 or whatever and riah's is
that's when I realized jay-z's different
yeah and so it's the same thing he's
writing down he could walk in he's out
in six minutes like he's a crazy his and
by the way learned the skill and he D
glorifies it now as a responsible father
and then
you know respect a member of our
community of the u.s. American community
you know he's like man like I had a lot
of spare time sitting on project inches
selling drugs yeah and I actually did
some of my time and I invested in myself
so all you out there listening no matter
what your social circumstances are no
who's listening to this podcast or
whether your demographic is but we all
share one thing in common
and it's it's you have a ticking heart
you have a thinking mind use that to
your advantage it's like we wouldn't you
and I wouldn't be here if we didn't if
we didn't use those to our advantage and
take advantage of the resources that we
could pull towards us then as we got
further and further long the resources
got grew and they become better so let
me let me finish my jay-z
you're gonna hate me or some a lot of
your folks in a me for this and it's not
a personal preference but I'm gonna go
Eminem oh okay good so I personally top
10 all-time yeah I think he's the most
talented rapper lyricists of all time no
one has ever rapped like him yeah it's
big it's hard to refute it would be hard
to refute he's not top 3 lyricist so
Eminem would tell you Big L is the best
lyricist yeah I would tend to agree with
that based on my personal preference but
Eminem has a substantially longer
discography unfortunately because Big Al
was murdered substantially longer sorry
at what was the peak and probably
continues to be the peak of lyricism
they made it about oh yeah the purest
form of rap man
yeah and so like and also that's beyond
the point that's me arguing from the
respect of a hip-hop hit don't forget
what he did for rap music
he took rap music from my inner city
ghetto project you know drug bill and
gangbanging area and put it in every
suburban home in the country and in the
world
I remember when him and dr. Dre came out
and he was like what what would he say
and he's in the basement I forget the
lyrics but I remember just listen that
over and over and over again yes oh yeah
absolutely so are you adding the two
gotta tip your cap because when you a
free fax he took hip hop from a urban
art form to a international art form
single-handedly almost all right JC
you're too for lo way and you gave all
the background all the way yeah and this
is something that
me to say out loud because I'm not a fan
I don't believe what he's done I think
he's part of the problem is it relates
to what you people in our generation
have think about hip-hop but so you
gotta give it to Drake man oh yeah
the guy's been a legend for 10 years now
and people who were 14 15 to 25 26 they
don't know who jay-z and Eminem I have
no clue they barely know Lil Wayne at
the tail end of his wants a lustrous
career but so here's my thought on Drake
Drake's the perfect example of the
science at work he is pure science yeah
which is here Jimmy what she understands
here's what works so I'm gonna go do
what works I'm not going to just do what
I want to do no and he's definitely
intelligent about doing that which by
the way makes him great
which makes him great oh I love that
thank you brother right like people will
definitely hate that you said Drake
because I think that he's not a rapper
but if you hated your hater the haters
are hating all right man listen where
can people find you on the Internet
all right so yeah obviously my Twitter
I'm in hedge ID bail HED GE ye dee da le
just a lot of hot tubs in finance
alphabet soup over there alphago I mean
I have a weird name Dairy still so hedge
eyes obviously my firm my brand wrapped
that D ie
yeah so look I'm a very accessible guy I
like to engage in the debate I you know
I I may not be the smartest guy in the
room but I'm definitely gonna be one of
the hardest guys in any room I walk into
I I gotta say you uh where did I see you
were Oh with Julia on CNN yeah and I saw
you Julius great she's really sure and
you were just dropping down out of time
and I was like you know my man is like
Stock Exchange up on the catwalk and he
is lighting a fire up there in the hood
to the stock exchange man where we met
where's next I love it I love it yeah
white house all right so uh all right
people can can find you on Twitter I
appreciate you doing this we'd ever have
to do it again
absolutely we might have to get we had a
couple other friends that that might
have live it up the conversation even
more totally and next time we do it
though there would definitely be Bud
Light here so I appreciate you coming in
of course man thanks for having me I
appreciate you guys listening thank you